rated M for Mature
so what happened to your parents if you
don't mind me asking my parents went on
vacation and loved me with a babysitter
they never came back
we went to Savannah to find them but
they were already dead
this man found me and took care of me we
met up with other survivors we all tried
to make it but it didn't work
his name is Lee he taught me how to
survive he taught me how to shoot a gun
happened to him
the same thing that happens to everyone
Clementine wine
that's okay
she's been I have fun it was a dog one
way to find out wait
not
listen everyone just stay calm Zehra
get me bison tell us who you are
you know I half expected to see Lee walk
up next
and safety
I'm out looking for my people
our baby deserves rain
some of these folks ain't too keen it's
up to us to figure out a way out of here
anchor2 move kid
go on
don't need to see this
just get people killed
and we worked
No
they are weak and we are strong it's why
it falls to people like us to lead them
to safety
I'm not like you
did you see it it's right there butcher
horses Clem
sorry there's something in the tree
house and she wants me to get a video of
it to show you guys look by the door
speaking out I I think it's yes at it
look at that spoiler it's record yeah oh
no no here your mom wants to talk to you
hi mom hi hot trio baby raccoons Wow yep
Betty's cute uh-huh make sure you don't
try and touch him okay okay gotta go
talk to you later hey that's not any way
to say bye to your mother
yeah I'm here mom don't get my hat dirty
magic tomorrow it's not happen okay
you'll be nice to Sandra and don't pay
up too late I won't
that's class honey I love you too I miss
you don't worry sweetie happy home in a
few days okay see you soon
you